e herkese Tekrar merhaba pandemi de
yaşıyoruz bu yaşamakta olduğumuz
panelini artık üzerini iyice bilgisayar
bağımlısı yaptım dünya parmaklarımı
sonucu da parmaklara gittiğimizde
ayağımıza aşağı gelirken eğitimde yazılı
basılı elimizde tuttuğumuz okuma
malzemesi önemini ve değerini anlatmaya
kalkışmak herhalde toplantının başından
beri ile dinlediğim yaşayan konularında
bilgi biraz fazla kederim kalacağım ama
hakanca tıpta eğitim gibi halk hop
yayınlarda değerlerine hiç kaybetmeyecek
bu ikisine de kısa kısa değilim Sizlerde
kendi kararını verdim Şimdi evvela
eğitim eğitim eğitim gerekli en eski
toplumlarda ortaya çıkmış uygarlıkla
gelişmiş Hatta uygarlığı geliştirmiş bir
değer bir oldu insanlık tarihine
baktığımızda toplumların eğitimleri
oranında güçlendiğini görüyoruz duvarın
İnsanoğlu en
Bu Armağan nedir akıl ve düşüncedir Ebu
akıl ve düşüncenin gelişmesinde başrolü
oynayan eğitim günümüzde de ileri
ülkelerin arasında yer alabilmenin
olmazsa olmaz Bir toplumun bireylerin
yetişmesi Yurttaşlık bilinci kazanması
ülkesine insanlığa katkı olmasın Pardon
eğitim ve öğrenimi doğrudan doğruya
yapılardır yol haritasını eğitimin
getirdiği aydınlanma doğrultusunda çizen
ülkeler gelişirken onu göz ardı edenler
gelip almışlardır eğitimin Başkada
Sıkıysa eski çağlardan beri insanlara
yaşam ve düşüncelerini yansıtıp ya
Böylece insanlığı uygarlık yolunda
evlenmesini sağlayan yapılardır ben
burada bu oldu kapsamında bunları okuma
malzemesi diye adlandırdı yorum bu okuma
malzemesi diye adlandırdığım yaptıkların
önemini ve değerini Sizlere daha iyi
bu yapabilmek için biraz da Osmanlı ve
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti durumda değinerek
Ağır kökenden biraz ineceğim kökenini
hatırlayacağım eğitim tarihinden birkaç
söz söylemek istedim yani bunu çok
üstüne giden tarihsel bakınca eğitimin
ilk insanlarla ortaya çıkan ve artık
hızına yetişemediğimiz iletişimle
başladığını görüyoruz iletişimin çıkış
noktası ise insanın aklından geçeni
duygu ve düşüncelerini açıklayabilmek
üzere aklı coğrafyalarda karpuz seslerle
yaşam bulan bir oldu yani İlk ve ifade E
bunu paylaşır yaygınlaşmasını sağlayan
yazılır bunun içindeki sümerlerin
milattan önce 4 binlerde icat ettiği
yazı tarihin başlangıcı kabul edilmiştir
cisim ve isimlerle işte kayalara oyulan
şekillerle paylaşım dönemleri ise ta
o öncesi çağlar olarak tanımlanır yazı
toplumların duygularını düşüncelerini
köklerine tariflerini yaşamışım yani
anlatmalarını sağlarken yüzyıllar boyu
kuşaktan kuşağa geçen okuma malzemesi
olan yazılı belgelerde insanların
birbirlerini tanımalarına bilgilerini
paylaşmalarını alalım insanın Çağrı Yine
deneyimlerinin birikimlerine Yazı dili
ile paylaşılması yla eğitimin bir incir
aracı olan kitap dergi özetle gibi
yazılı okuma malzemeleri de böyle oluştu
bunların değerlendirilmesi oranında her
birinden insanla insanlığın ilerlemesine
ayrı ayrı katkıları oldu e yazdığı
kitaplar belgeler eski Yunan ve roma'dan
biri düşünürlerin dünyayı aydınlatan
görüşlerini şak daha kuşağı taşıyor
insanları aydınlatmayı ulaştırıp Bunlar
alın tabii her evrede insanların her
evresinde ayrı bir
bu değer ve önem taşıp onun götürdü
yaratıcılıkla icat edilen teknolojik
ürünler Yani bir sürü bu teknoloji
devrimi geçiriyor Dünya çok ürün icat
ediyor bunların hepsinin bir yaratıcı
köklenen aydınlanmayla getirmiş
olgulardır lan Yaşamımızın vazgeçilmez
parçalarım olurken bunların başında en
başında gelen vakanın sağladı bol okuma
malzemesi toplumların ilerlemesinde
anahtarı olur Johannes gutenberg'in 66
yüzyıldan beri kullanılan Çin baskısı
tekniğini geliştirir 1440 yılında icat
ettiği matbaa ile yazı malzeme nasılsın
Çok düşük maliyetlerle hızla basılıp
kitlelere ulaştırılması dünyanın
profilini değiştirdi matbaa kullanmaya
başlayan Avrupa ülkelerine çok sayıda
okuma malzemesi yıllardır Osmanlıların
içerdiği bilgi
ve hızla yayılırken maliyeti de çok çok
ucuz bir an yayınlar okuryazarlığın
sayısının hızlı akmasını sağladı yeni
fikirleri araştırmaları okuyarak çuval
an bilinçli bilgili kimseler ve onları
yetiştiren okullar batıda Çünkü belki
olurken matbaa ile gelişen bir sel
eğitimi göz ardı eden ülkeler yine
uygarlıklar ilerlemekten uzak kaldırıyor
şu konumuz açısından altını çizeceğim
nokta okuma malzemesinin önemini ve
değerini En çok da matbaalarda
kitapların yayınlanmasıyla Anlaşılır bir
neden ders kitaplarına değişik önemli
yazarlar alıcılar için içeren okula
parçaları koyuyorlar gençleri değişik
görüşlerle tanıştırırsa onlara yeni
ufuklar açsın diye bu bireylerde
karşılaştırmalı görür Analitik yani
inceleyici bakış açısı kendi sentezini
yapabilme yetenek geliştiriyor ara
bir acılık ve yaratıcılık da ayran böyle
görüşüyor Sözün Özü Gençler bu olguların
sorumluluğu ve bilinci yetişir O da
çağların başına en güçlü devlet devlet
olan Osmanlı Devleti'ne gelince Rönesans
ve reformun getirdiği aydınlanmayla
batıya kendi çıkarları uğruna bilimsel
tutsaklığın karanlığına sürükleyen kimse
dedim adamlarının nüfusunu kırdığını
gören Osmanlı uleması lıquı aynı yani
onların uğradığı akıbete uğrayıp da
kendi nüfuslarına higb etmekten korkarak
Sözde din adına yasaklamalı ara ülkeye
batıdaki gelişmeleri uzaklık Hatta
matbaayı bileyim 250 yıl yaydım şekilde
kullandık bak Böylece bilimselliğin
sağladığı düşünsen özgürlüğü öpüşmeyen
Bu nedenle de oturun teknolojik
gelişmelere uzak olan Osmanlı'da
tanzimattan meşrutiyete kadar ilime esas
alan aydınlığa yetişemedim
ve edebiyat görüşemedim Roman tiyatro
gibi halkı bilgilendirip aydınlatacak
kitaplarda yazılamadı Hatta gazete bile
çıkarılamadı çeviriler yapıldı
adaptasyonlar yapıldı çok az birkaç
kitap yazıldı ama böyle bir şey lazımsa
söyle de a kültür diye birşeymiş soyduk
oluşmadı cahillik içinde doğan Osmanlı
Devleti de hızla ilerleyip söktü bu
tarihsel akışı gören Atatürk Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti'ni kurarken bilmesem de
Böylece Türkiye hep bağımsızlık hem de
çağdaş uygarlığa erişme savaşını kazandı
böyle seçmemin bu sağlıktan farklı bir
nedeni var Bu ilk Dünya Savaşı sonunda
yenilip dağılan Osmanlı Devleti'ni
işgale uğrayan türk topraklarının ulusal
oturup savaşında kurtarılmasının
ardından Bağımsız Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti'nin kurulmasını ve
çağdaşlaşma hareketi olan Türk
Devriminin yapılması inancı bi
o önüne aldıkları için gelişe ve
karanlıkta kalan jüri olan nice
tutsaklığa olumsuzluk kadar aydınlanma
yolunda açan hareket olduğu için Atatürk
ne diyor Kurtuluş Savaşı sadece Kendimiz
için olsaydı çok daha az kaldı dökülür
daha çabuk biter de şimdi Atatürk'ün
başlattığı Türk Devriminin Evrensel
edeceğim genç Türkiye Cumhuriyeti'nin
ile ülkelerine yer alarak üzülmekte olan
haklara bağımsızlık kazanıp
aydınlatmaları için bir örnek oluşturma
uzun hedefle var Ulusal Hedef ise
yüzyıllarda Günsel değerlerle Ümmet
olarak yönetilmiş eğitilmiş yargılanmış
olan toplumda olmuş olmuşlar
yerleştirmek Yurttaşlık bir iş bilincini
geliştirmek yüklü kıvırcığı yaşayacağız
eşofman bu değişikliği okuryazarlığın
yaygınlaştırılması ve eğitimin
bilimselliğe layık ve ulusal Lada
yazdırılmasını Öz alacağını biliyor
17. kablolar Cumhuriyeti Ümran kablolar
yeni Türkiye Cup geldi Osmanlı
Devleti'nin alfabesi olan ve kullanılan
maddeleri olduğu savıyla
değiştirilemeyen Arap harfli harflerini
hem Türkçe Uyumsuz olduğunda hem de zor
öğrenen öğrenildiğinde nokul örgü şeyi
okuryazar olması ve engellediğini
biliyorlar gerçekten de cumhuriyetin
kurulma aşamasında yüzden 3'ü kadın
olmak üzere ülkenin sadece yüzde onu
okur yazar ve okur yazar okuma yazma da
bir ev Derdimi anlatıyorum ama bunun
yanı sıra genel bütçeden eğitime ayrılan
tutardı yüzde altı geçmiyor ben her
düşün şimdi bu koşullarda okullarda
okuma malzemesi olmaması bir yala ancak
kulaktan kulağa geçen halk edebiyatı ve
çok yüksek suya seslenen Divan Edebiyatı
az sayıda yaptıkları çalışmalardan başka
okumayan malzeme
Yok yok Cumhuriyet grubu A Bunu asla
söylemem nedenim çok Günaydın bir söyle
biliyorsunuz bir saatte evrimiyle de
geçmişimiz var mı koptu diyorlar Bu
doğru bir semti Çünkü yayın yok Yani
asıl bir şey yok yazılmıştır yok Bir
tane tür doğmamış edebiyat doğmamış sana
doğmamış bunlar hep tanzimatla kapılar
açılıyor ve esas cumhuriyet devrinde
gelişiyor o zamana kadar ilk adımları
atılıyor sayısal veri bile var Yani
bunun için Yani toplam yayın malzemesi
aşı belgeleri ait bir şeyler Resmi
kayıtlar hükümettir kayıtları hepsi
dahil yaklaşık 30 bu kalem yazılıp
malzeme var Onların öyle çok çabuk
olabilir Yeter ki ilgili olsun Sanırım
antolojik ve altta Aşık malzemesi olan
şeyler herhalde kağıda bilimsel hazırlık
ok
o evde işletim sistemi kullanılıyor
ülkede bu çok farklı yaşam profili olan
öp kuşaklar yetiştiriyor böyle döküldü
birliğinde sağlanamaz bu kara tablonun
ancak toplumsal Cahilin giderilmesiyle
değişik önce anlaşıldığından 3 Mart
1924'te Türkiye Büyük Millet Meclisi'nde
kabul edilen öğrenebilir yasası ile
eğitim kurumları ulusal laik bilimsel
temelde birleştirilir bir Kasım 1928'de
dedin sen olduğu öne sürülerek bir türlü
a değiştirilemeyen Arap harflerinin
yerine neden harflerine dayalı Türk
alfabesinde geçiriyor bu iki değişim çok
yokluğunu çağdaş uygarlık yolunda
ilerlemesini sağlayan en önemli adımlar
ama değişmiş bilmiyordu önce yeni
harfleri verecek bir arkada kitabın
yazılması toplumun okul lazer yapılması
ve yeni harflerle bilimsel eğitimi
geliştirdik ders kitaplarının yapılması
gerek
Ama bunlar yapılırken halk devrimden
hemen sonra yetişkinlere yeni harfleri
öğretmek üzere açılan millet mektepleri
değil kaç ayda binlerce Yurttaş okumaya
zordu eğitimde bakımı eğitimlere
katılarak yapılan değişikler iplerle
kız-erkek ayrımı yapılmadan ilköğretim
zorunlu o hatta bunun büyük çoğunluğu
yaşadık öyle taşınmasını öğretmenleri
yetiştirmek okulların açılması
kararlaştırır Türkiye durum Ülkesi Onun
için üretim aksamaması için eğitimi her
adet ayın tarım sektöründe çalışacak köy
çocuklarının ayağına götüren Gül
okullara ardından da 1940 yılında bu
okulların yüksek düştü oluşturan Köy
Enstitüleri açıldı Böylece genç
Cumhuriyet kısa zamanda kökenli
aydınlığa takılmış bu eğitim
seferberliği hızlı ortaokul yazarlara
önemlidir önümü değeri anlaşılır okuma
malzemesi sağlamak devletini ağaç
bu bulmak gerekti ve sorun
okuryazarlığın azından araştırmacı da
gelişmediğinden okula malzemesi çok daha
hızlı ve unutmamak gerek yok yaşayan bir
toplum olabilmek toplumsal farkındadır
ağır gerektirir bu çok önemlidir ama
toplumsal farkındalık oluşacak bunun
sürdürmesi da hala mıdır bu bireylere
vatandaşlık bir önce insanlık olgusu
ülkelerde dünyada siyasal bilimsel
tekrar yer sağlık bunların hepsinin boş
okuma çalışma alışkanlığına sağlıklı
bilinen bir gerçek bu kapsamda ülkenin
gerçeği olan bu exip iyi karşılayabilmek
için a 1940 yolunda çok önemli bir adım
atıldı ve eski Yunan Roma filozoflarının
doğru batılı düşünürlerin batının
ilerlemesine büyük payı çok büyük payı
olan dünya klasikleri çevirmesi
kararlaştırıldı ve hızla bu işe girişi
Bu karar alınırken çevrilen kitapları
okuyanlara bu kitapları düz
bu borcumuz öğrenecekleri Böylece Türk
yazarların da daha nitelikli yapıtları
yazmaya üzülecekler katılmıştı Ama bunun
çevirmesine kolay olmadı önce bu
kitaplarında nefesini anlayarak
çevirecek leri doğu batı dillerine
öğretmek üzere 1935 yılında Ankara dil
tarih coğrafya fakültesi kuruldu
üniversiteden Ankara Üniversitesi'nden
önce açılan Bu okulda farklı diller
öğrenerek yetişen yerim adamları ve
aydınlardan kurulan çeviri heyetlerine
yoğun çalışmalarıyla dünya
klasiklerinden altı yılda 467 kitap
çeviri yayınlandı bu 1950'de 674 1967'de
100'e ulaştı rostow büyüklüğüne bakmadan
kitabı bilgi insan haklarına bir parçası
olarak yaklaşan bu hareket dünyada Türk
valiz masası olarak değerlendirilir
Türkiye Burada da niçin Doğu topla
bağımsız Çağdaş
Allah yolunda Esin aynı işte burada
Türkiye örneğini özetlediği gibi eğitim
ve öğrenim de okuma malzemesi önemi bunu
çok eski çağlardan beri vazgeçilemeyen
temel bir gerek olmasıdır değeri ise
yine çok eski çağlardan beri yeni
yetişenlerin geleceğe taşınması Enişte
sen de değişmem Köprü çok teşekkür
ederim dinlediğiniz için